what's up my name is samuel leeds and if
you want to be a property investor
you basically need money and you need
property investment deals that's what
you need so where are you going to get
money from
where are you going to get property
investment deals from well i'll tell you
what i did i'm going to keep this real
ridiculous simple people oh that's so
simple well okay
just write it i got deals from right
move
listen people say oh you know if you get
deals on rightmove you're an amateur no
no
when you're an amateur fine you might go
to right move and then you become
professional
and then you start going off market you
know back doors you start advertising
but when you become seasoned again you
start going back to right move because
you know let me tell you why
i'm right move there are hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of property
deals on rightmove
so if you know what to look for if you
know how to calculate the return on
investment
if you don't have to negotiate a deal
you can get a deal
online from right move right now
everything's open as that agents are
open
construction's open surveyors are open
everything's open
there's loads of motivated people so if
you're struggling to find deals
you just got to get good at finding
deals believe me they're everywhere
okay cool next money how you gonna get
money what is it if you don't have any
money you have to save up no
that's what they tell you to do they
tell you to
work hard save up money but what happens
is
even if you're saving up money saving up
a thousand pounds a month
okay okay maybe you need thirty thousand
pounds by the time you get that thirty
thousand pounds in thirty months house
prices have gone up and you're like oh
man
i need to save up another ten months
then you get demoralized and then
suddenly something
comes up you get married and you need to
spend the 30 grand on that
and then you start over again and this
repeats itself until you're 67 years old
and then you retire where are you going
to get money from
you're not going to use your own money
you're going to use other people's money
samuel just sells people dreams no this
is just what i did
this is what many people do so the deals
are okay the deals are there
where are you going to get the money
from let me tell you something most
people
because they're told to do this they
save up money they put it in the bank
you're going to go find all those people
the suckers if you want to call them
that
that have followed this and then have
got money they've saved it up
they've put it in the bank and there's
there's millions of people with millions
of pounds okay there's not
there's not a limited amount of money
there's an unlimited amount of money
i mean geez you know they just printed
off another 150
billion pounds by the way a billion is a
thousand million
if you can't get your hands on one
million you got a problem just one
one they just printed off 150
billion that's a million a million a
million a million a million a million a
million a million a thousand times
and then again and then again and then
they get 150 times they just printed
that
and then a few months ago they did they
printed off 200 billion
and people are saving this money they're
saving their pennies they're putting it
in the bank
and it's depreciating in value it's
shrinking in value
like in zimbabwe where you go and get a
taxi and they say it's a trillion
a trillion zimbabwe dollars to get a
taxi it's like a trillion what what
happened i'll tell you what happened
they kept printing money money money
money money and it shrunk and now it's
worthless that's what's happening
in the uk they're printing money
so what you need to do is you need to
approach folks who've got loads of money
in the bank because they've worked
harder they've followed the system and
you just say hey
i got a deal i got it from rightmove i
got it some from a zoopla
i got it from gumtree i got it from
oprah i got it from spare room i got it
from a friend i got it from networking i
got it by
speaking out on social media and saying
i'm a property investor and even though
i had some haters and even though some
people laughed at me and even some
people said you're not a property
investor you've only got one house you
haven't got any houses you speaking it
out you're speaking into existence and
guess what
now i've got this deal now i've got this
property but guess what i haven't got
any money
for the deal but i'm already thinking
that you've got 50 000 pounds in the
bank
and you're making how much how much of
the bank giving you again
zero and and your friend will go oh no
it's really good i've just moved it
around from this i said to that i said
so they're giving me zero
it was zero point three percent now it's
0.9 it's tripled
i'm like listen with respect if it
starts with a zero is bad
so the bank are giving you zero point
something percent
how about this give me half of your
savings 25 grand
let me put that into this deal and i'll
give you ten percent
return on investment guaranteed but of
course you've got the deal which is
giving you 20
return on investment you're making the
same as they're making but they put in
all the money and you put in nothing
that's called a joint venture that's
called raised finance that's how you buy
properties then you snowball
you get better at raising finance you
get it better asking people for money
you get more well networked you find
better deals the best way to build
relationships with estate agents is to
buy from them when you buy from them
they'll pass you better deals again and
again
i've been in the game now for 12 years
i've been buying houses for 12 years i
get the best deals
i've got people trying to joint venture
with me all the time it's easy
is it going to be easy for you it
depends on how you find it easy
i mean i mean i mean people say sami you
make everything look so easy as if it's
a negative i'm like that's a good thing
cristiano ronaldo makes football look
easy because he's good at it i'm glad i
make property investing a little easy
and yeah i do make it look easy because
you know why
complexity is the thief of execution you
know most people try making it really
complicated to make himself look really
clever i'm like now i'm working class
boy
i'm 29 years old i become a
multi-millionaire
via property very successful
was it easy to begin with i don't know
everything's hard
if you've got a nine to five it's hard
being fat's hard but working out and
being slim is
so hard i've done both being broke's
hard being rich is also hard
life's freaking hard get over it but if
you're gonna work hard anyway you may as
well get rich and the best way to get
rich
just look on sunday times look at the
sunday times
like 90 of them are investing in
property
you want to invest in property you can
do that too what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to make the barrier to entry i'm
trying to make it lower to help more
people become on the property ladder
because that's what's going to bring
financial freedom
that's what's going to bring financial
independence that's what the government
is trying to actually stop
you doing but tell me what about help to
buy schemes i thought that a government
trying to help people
nope nope they're telling you to buy a
house to live in
and they're telling you it has to be a
new build they want you to be poor
that's what they want they want you to
buy a house to live in so you've got a
big mortgage
a house that you live in the mortgage is
bad debt because the house isn't giving
you any money
you want to buy an investment property
and the investment property makes you
money that's good debt
they don't want you doing that the
sister don't want you doing what i'm
teaching
the media don't like this the media tell
you you know buy a holiday and pay for
it later and whack it on a credit card
and as soon as you stop
buying properties creatively they don't
like it so
anyway hope this video was helpful you
want to know more about raising finance
and joint ventures
because that's the skill this business
is a numbers business it's also a people
business
property investing is a people people
business you need to be able to get good
at finding deals who do they come from
people
i need to find good again investors
who's who are investors they're people
you need to be able to raise finance you
need to be able to join venture if you
want to get on in this
in this world so listen i'm gonna i'm
running a webinar
on how to raise finance how to joint
venture uh it's free
it's a free webinar and i'll leave a
link in the description get yourself
booked on it's gonna be amazing
and uh do me a favor i do a video every
single day
just smash the like button subscribe
i'll see you tomorrow
peace out